thank you
hey what's up I'm Kim BFC here okay I'm
gonna make myself sound really old here
just for a second but about 10 years ago
there was a vibrant ecosystem of a ton
of different tablets there's all kinds
of tablets there is like iPads versus
Android tablets all these fights going
on there were small screen tablets big
screen tablets and all the Android
tablets were sort of anchored by
Google's family of Nexus tablets so we
had the Smash Hit Nexus 7 and the cult
classic Nexus 10 but then Google kind of
got a little bit lost with Android
tablets and Chrome OS tablets a little
bit in there for a bit and they made a
few bad ones in a row and then they just
gave up
like they literally just gave up stopped
making tablets but something else that's
picked up a whole bunch of steam since
then is a new product category Smart
Home displays so Google bought nest and
we've seen this Nest Hub and the nest
Hub Max came out and this is a growing
category every single month so at some
point during all of this Google probably
thought wait a second we're making all
these Smart Home displays and what is a
smart home display it's basically just a
cheap tablet
so what if we just made a cheap tablet
that could turn into a smart home
display
and so that's how we got this this is
the pixel tablet so I've been using this
tablet for a few weeks now and look it's
not amazing or super premium or high-end
or exciting uh and neither are any of
the other Smart Home displays but I do
want to talk about it it's also a little
bit interesting and underrated and how
important this tablet could be to other
tablets so let's talk about it so as a
tablet this thing is pretty simple I
really like the soft touch finish on the
back this is the porcelain color and it
hides fingerprints really really well
feels solid in the hand it's actually
made of metal but you honestly could
never tell just holding it thanks to
this coating but it's very basic single
camera on the back corner volume buttons
with the inset fingerprint reader that
doubles as a power button up at the top
there's a set of speakers on the left
and right that sounds okay but really
doesn't have much bass at all and the
USBC Port is on the left hand side it's
not too big it's not too heavy and on
the front is an 11 inch 2560 by 1600
60hz LCD display with bezels just thin
enough to hold it and not be a problem
and the display does not get
particularly bright and it's not the
fastest thing in the world but it is
running the same tensor G2 chip as the
pixel 7s but I just I I cannot call this
tablet fast not sure if it's under
clocked or what's happening here but it
behaves very much like a basic mid-range
Android tablet and that's because that's
basically what it is this is a 499
dollar tablet and it comes with the dock
in the box that you can buy separately
if you want to if you want an additional
one for 130 so I would say
tame your expectations here like it's it
works and it's it does what it's
supposed to but I would just I would say
tame your expectations so this speaker
dock comes on the box which I think is
super cool and it's actually the only
way to charge the tablet that comes in
the box there is no USBC Cable in here
it's just the dock which has a barrel
connector that connects to the wall and
the dock is basically it's just a
speaker in a box really with some pins
super simple the pins kind of retract a
little bit when you touch them which is
cool but basically the premise is
there's some magnets in the dock as you
can see here with this magnet paper and
there's some magnets in the tablet which
you can also see here with this magnet
paper and so when you line those up and
connect the dock to the tablet it just
pops right onto those pins and the pins
carry both power and data so now it's
charging and the audio quality should be
improved because it's now using the
speaker in the dock it works pretty darn
quickly too thankfully it's not
Bluetooth pairing or anything it's just
literally a physical connection for the
the data so it's just like connecting
like an iPad to a keyboard it just works
right away it holds it at a pretty good
angle too it's basically straight up and
down it looks just like a nest home hub
when you put it on the dock like that
magnets are pretty strong you can pop it
off with one hand if you want to
I'm just uh I'm just glad that this
comes in the box and isn't an additional
hundred thirty dollars first of all the
charging speed is up to 15 watts which
is
not that fast it's a tablet battery so
it's pretty big takes a while to charge
um and then the the speaker in here is
not that great I would say it feels on
par with like the nest Hub Mini at Best
so the speakers in the tablet are uh
like I said they're fine but they really
lack a lot of bass and then when you add
it to the speaker dock you're getting
like 20 to 30 more volume but it's
mostly just adding the bass back but
it's not super loud here I'll give you
a little sample
not a ton of bass right
[Music]
all low end
and it's quick too it's immediate as
soon as I pop it off back to the
speakers but it's not the it's not the
loudest thing in the world honestly it's
I guess it's fine this dock cannot be
used as a Bluetooth speaker or anything
else when a tablet isn't attached but
honestly I don't think you'd want to
it's basically just sits there and is
waiting for the tablet to be attached to
it what's funny though is it does help
with the battery so the battery life on
this tablet was decent for me but it did
have particularly weak standby life for
some reason it would drop like 10
overnight sometimes which could be a bug
either way the idea is when you're done
using it you can pop it onto the dock
and it is literally just a smart speaker
now if you really wanted to you could
buy another one and put it in a
different room and then when it's in the
kitchen per se it'll show you certain
things when it's in the bedroom it'll
show you other things but it is a
hundred and thirty dollars per Dock and
I'm now starting to think that that's
the more overpriced thing among this
bundle so just know what you're getting
into that but I think really what I
realized is this docking feature is cool
but it's not the most interesting part
of this tablet for me it's the
headlining feature because it's the cool
thing that it does but as I was talking
about there was this whole tablet
ecosystem like 10 years ago and seeing
what Google does with the software for
this tablet could give us a window into
how Google can anchor Android tablets
again going forward so I was really
curious about the software so here's
what I found number one I really like
the new dock the software dock so the
home button at the bottom you can swipe
up at any time and all the same gestures
work like normal but there's a new
gesture where you just grab the Bottom
bar and swipe up just a little bit and
that brings up a dock which is the exact
same order of whatever apps you had in
your home screen dock it also shows up
in multitasking and then from there you
can switch to a recent app or initiate
multitasking by dragging something to
half the screen to get two things going
at once it works great it simple I use
it all the time for going back and forth
between two things quickly so I really
like that then number two multi-user
support is so sick and the iPad should
seriously be taking notes on this so
anytime you want either from the
notification tray or from the lock
screen or anywhere that you see that
profile picture for your account you can
switch users when you set up a new user
at first you basically go through the
whole setup process as if you're setting
up a brand new tablet and then that
second person can sign into their apps
and set up their home screen and their
widgets and everything and you can
switch back and forth by logging into
each one literally just with your
fingerprint it's exactly as simple as it
should be it could also totally be like
one person's personal profile and
business profile so you never get the
two confused or I don't know just a
profile for your burner accounts
whatever you want to make it the point
is tablets are often used at home and by
families that have more than one person
so the ability to just like log into
your kids account and not have them
worry about accidentally buying thirty
thousand dollars of I don't know
Minecraft credits or something it's a
pretty obviously great feature and then
number three of course Hub mode this is
the mode that sort of pops up when you
get it onto the dock uh that they had to
build of course because they turned this
into a Smart Hub I kind of end up just
using it like a Smart Hub a lot of the
time that it's on this dock I don't
touch it as much I just use voice
controls which all work and then I have
a clock here you can do like a photo
gallery type thing or rotating pieces of
Art and of course the smart home display
controls are available at the bottom
corner but it just kind of lives like
that I have it in the kitchen most of
the time
nice oh this is also fun fact the the
first tablet that has Chromecast built
in as a Target so you can use it as a
Target to Chromecast things to it
I would never do that but you can do
that so the number four last but not
least is the app situation this is
something we talk a lot about with
Android tablets and there was a lot of
promise with this version and with this
tablet that there would be a whole bunch
of new tablet optimized apps and that
that experience would be meaningfully
different
and it's not well I guess you could say
it's a little bit true so Google can say
that their own apps are now all
optimized and take full advantage of the
larger display so you know you can be
confident anytime you open a Google app
on this Google tablet it's going to look
great and that's awesome but for all of
the rest of the apps that make the world
go round all the third-party apps all
the stuff that you probably are thinking
about when getting a tablet that you're
going to use there is no meaningful
difference in that situation right now
so a lot of them are still uh
big phone apps I would say Instagram is
still a giant phone app Twitter is still
a giant phone app Tesla is still a giant
phone app Expedia stole a giant phone
app cash app is still not optimized
neither is Tick Tock it still kind of
looks weird SoundCloud is like half
optimized I guess Pocket Casts is also
halfway there looking like a giant phone
app overdrop weather is still a blown up
phone app and the list goes on and on
they have this thing where you can uh
double tap the space to the left or to
the right to move it over to the side to
make it more one-handable but I mean
yeah that's it it's just a big phone app
the app ecosystem for Android tablets is
still to this day even now that this has
arrived it's still the biggest weakness
of an Android tablet and the incentive
it's got to be on developers of course
but most of their incentive is to be as
simple and streamlined as possible and
if you can just make one iPad app that
covers all iPads you'll do it but if you
can make one tablet app
it won't necessarily work on all Android
tablets so the incentive is still kind
of tough well actually there is one app
that Google can say that they got
optimized before the iPad and that's the
calculator
they did do a full scientific not
scientific but a full-on calculator
there's a history over here to the side
there's the readout which you can change
the size of a light and dark theme all
this stuff it's
pretty good
your move Apple some other little random
things that didn't quite fit into the
full review uh when it's docked on the
charger it default charges up to 90 not
100 but I do think that's smart IT
preserves the battery life overall
there's also no headphone jack on this
tablet just so you know and then in case
you're wondering the camera quality is
very much in line with the rest of this
tablet's Hardware pretty mid it's good
enough for basic video calls and
document scanning but nobody's shooting
any movies on this thing at the end of
the day though my conclusion is this
two in one devices are typically they're
funny because they're they're always
like slightly worse at one of the things
that they're trying to be this is a two
in one device it's a tablet and it's a
smart home hub so I was wondering as I
got it like what is it going to be
compromised at is it worse at one or
worse at the other turns out it's a
decent cheap Android tablet
and it's a slightly below average
speaker dock home hub
uh but that's fine I think those two
things are close enough together and are
simple enough that it makes sense at
least I would personally love a super
high-end version of this I'd be so down
for like a 120 hertz super fast nice
premium tablet that also could dock
whenever I want on a nice speaker and
become like this high-end like Boombox
thing but I also know that that would be
super expensive and would have a much
much smaller Target demographic and
probably wouldn't sell enough to exist
well so
this is the thing that makes sense and I
think it may actually sell a decent
amount and we'll see how it does until
the next one thanks for watching
catch in the next one peace
foreign
[Music]